[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
7 breakdown video there are a few more
scenes from the season 7 trailer that I
want to discuss when I made my breakdown
video for the trailer I received a lot
of comments asking me about the scenes
that were taking place beyond the wall
with Jon Snow and torment if you're one
of my longtime subscribers then you most
likely know exactly what has taken place
in those scenes but if you're new to
this channel and you haven't seen all
the spoilers and leaked photos then
you're probably not aware this video
will contain spoilers and I will also be
referencing the plot leaks so proceed
with caution in the season 7 trailer we
see 12 people that appear to be
surrounded by someone or something
they're all standing in a circle and
they're all in a defensive stance most
likely preparing to fight I have a
pretty good idea who most of these
people are but there are a few of them
that I am completely unsure about so I'm
going to need everyone's help so we can
try and decide who else is with Jon Snow
and torment on this mission a few months
back reports started to come out about
the Game of Thrones production team
showing up in Iceland preparing to film
scenes that are going to be taking place
beyond the wall whenever Game of Thrones
films in Iceland it was always for
scenes shot beyond the wall and this is
not going to be any different photos
also started to circulate online as
actors began to show up in Iceland to
film D scenes but we still had no idea
how many people were actually going to
be involved with this scene we didn't
get a great photo from the set as a
group of characters were filming one of
these scenes and when you zoom in on
this photo you can see that there are at
the very least nine characters all
dressed in wildling type clothes which
is exactly what john foreman and the
other men in the circle are wearing but
as you can see in the trailer there are
at least 12 characters beyond the wall
there could even be in more than 12
people this scene in the trailer of them
standing in a circle could be after some
of the characters have already died but
they stopped the evidence we had thus
far I'm going to say there are 12
characters for now more people could
show up before this fight is over you
never know but what I did find
interesting is that the
they came out all the way back in
October and the flood League said this
would happen I'm going to read this
specific episode from the leak then
we're going to get into the evidence
that I have that came out so far at some
point next season John and Davos are
going to go down a Dragonstone to meet
with Daenerys and Tyrion during this
meeting John and Dallas are going to
tell Daenerys about the third beyond the
wall apparently Daenerys isn't going to
believe John at first so join eventually
besides that in order for everyone in
the south to believe him he is going to
need to get proof so he decides he's
going to go north of the wall and
capture a white to bring it back down
south to show everyone in order for him
to get the help that he needs the league
says that during episode six John is
going to arrive at eastwatch-by-the-sea
apparently tormund had a Brotherhood
without banners member locked into jail
there the Brotherhood without banners
were on a mission from the Lord of Light
to fight the White Walkers John then
leads a small force which includes beric
Dondarrion Thoris of mere tormund
Giantsbane Jorah Mormont and Gendry
while they're on this mission the team
is attacked by the night Kings army
including a zombie polar bear which ends
up killing Thoris of Mirror they get
surrounded on a frozen lake nearly about
to be killed but Daenerys shows up with
their dragons she then flies most of
them to safety but she leaves John
behind who is most likely still
surrounded on the frozen lake
apparently the night team is then able
to kill her dragon Vissarion and
resurrected as his own zombie dragon
Mount John is almost killed by the
encroaching horde of whites but then
benjin swoops in to save him
benjin sends the wounded John off on his
horse before benjin is swarmed and
presumably killed
now all that sounds very intense and it
might sound too unrealistic even for
Game of Thrones fans I have a lot of new
subscribers since I last talked about
this so I'll quickly show all of you how
much this leek has right thus far based
off all the footage photos and reports
that I had photos were leaked months ago
that showed John and Davos on the beats
of Dragonstone with Daenerys now I have
no idea what they talked about but
whatever it was causes John to leave the
island with more people than he showed
up with John and Davos set sail from
Dragonstone with Jorah and Gendry
which is two of the people he will be
taken with them beyond the wall we also
saw in the trailer that someone has a
war
hammer and most of us have seen the
photo of Gendry on the beach with Davos
and Tyrion and he does have a Warhammer
with him plus I've made other videos
talking about gentry going on his
mission so I would definitely say that's
gentry what's the Warhammer in that
circle of men in the season 7 trailer
photos also started to come out of a set
that Game of Thrones was using to film
that's white capture hunt as you can see
there is a man-made frozen lake here
which the league said John and his team
will be surrounded on and that's exactly
what it looked like was happening in the
trailer I think this is them getting
surrounded on that frozen lake in a
report also came out that said they
hired over 300 extras to use his wife
then the rest would be digitally added
so we will probably see John and all
these other men get attacked by
thousands of whites which is going to be
absolutely insane and we even got a
photo of John on this set filming on
this frozen lake it's kind of hard to
make out his face but the person once
said he took this photo said it was Jon
Snow John and Davos then film scenes on
the beach and Iceland when they go
beyond the wall they are not going to be
going through the wall at Castle black
then filming on this nude beach and
Iceland makes sense since they are
supposed to go to eastwatch-by-the-sea
in the season 7 trailers you can see a
gate opening up at the wall and at the
bottom of the gate it has spikes but
when you see the gate at Castle black
open up and you look at the bottom there
aren't any spikes so the gate that we
see in the season 7 trailer is
definitely not Castle black I do believe
this is eastwatch-by-the-sea that we are
seeing in the trailer but what's
interesting is when John and Davos
arrived in Iceland that's when a lot of
the other main players start to show up
in Iceland to meet John to film these
scenes
John and Davos are some of the first
people to arrive and they start to take
pictures with fans while they are there
Gaveston Gendry also show up near the
set and they both take a picture with
the same fan so they might have even
been filming scenes together because it
did appear that Davos and ginjury
were hanging out with each other all day
then we got a photo of Gendry and Thoris
of Mir who also took a picture with a
fan and this was all in Iceland and we
know that whenever they go to Iceland
it's going to be stuff taking place
north of the wall but this is when it
gets really interesting because these
next characters that were seen on set
have never filmed scenes together Jorah
Mormont torment
into hound all take a picture together
with a fan while they are at dinner
Jorah and tormund also take a picture
with benjin while they are there to film
so we can now start to piece together
who are all going to be filming with
John and Iceland while they do these
scenes north of the wall when we see
those 12 men in the trailer I definitely
believe some of those men are John
tormund den jury Jorah the hound
Thoros in barrack that is over half of
the group that's going to be in this
scene of the 12 men from the trailer
plus we have benjin and maybe goggles
I'm not so sure if Davos is going to go
with them beyond the wall for some
reason I feel like he could stay behind
and waited east watch while they do this
white capture mission but then again
Davos was in Iceland with them so he
could go with them but who do you think
these other characters in a trailer
could be there are potentially four
characters with John and this scene that
we haven't been able to name yet this is
where I'm going to need your feedback so
comment below and tell me who you think
these other four characters could be who
would be brave enough to go with John
and the rest of them to capture a wife
personally I think most of these
remaining characters are going to be
members of the Nights Watch from
eastwatch-by-the-sea but the unnamed
characters could also be other members
of the Brotherhood without banners we
got a photo of the Hound traveling most
likely north and you can see he is with
other members of the Brotherhood that
aren't Thoreau's in barrack
I think this photo of the Hound is him
traveling to the wall with the
Brotherhood he was told that the cold
winds are rising and that there is a
bigger purpose to serve I think some of
these members might go with him Thoris
and barrack beyond the wall I think some
of these twelve characters beyond the
wall are going to be sacrificed just to
raise the stakes and I seen most of them
will probably be unknown characters that
die in their scene but I did make a
prediction video about who I think would
die and then be risen as a white witch
you can watch after this video I'll put
the link down in the description but
there will most likely be some red
herrings in this group of 12 so they
will probably travel with a few unknown
nights Watchmen or a few unknown men
from the Brotherhood but there is still
a chance that all twelve of these
characters are main players let me know
if you think there are any other big
characters in this group besides the
ones that were seen on set do you think
Davos went beyond the wall he did travel
to Iceland of film and he is very loyal
to John he could have went with him to
back him
or do you think someone like Brienne
wins she wouldn't be a great addition to
this group plus she has a Valyrian steel
sword which is exactly what they're
going to need beyond the wall or do you
think someone even like Phelan might be
there Dionne was one to beat the dragon
stone with John now we didn't see him
get on the boat with John but he could
have taken his own boat anyone could
potentially want to prove to John that
he is loyal and sorry for what he'd done
so he could volunteer but I think the
remaining three or four men are most
likely going to be some unknown
characters that are going to be killed
we did get this photo during filming and
we only see nine or so characters here
so this could have been taken after some
of them already died but it's very
interesting that there are twelve
characters here in the trailer this is
very similar to the story of the last
hero which we did talk about in the
future of John snow collab video we did
have a strong feeling that something
like this was going to happen
but what else is interesting is this
isn't the first time we've seen a group
of 12 companions north of the wall if
you remember back in season 4 when the
night King turned the baby into a white
Walker we can see that the 19 had 12
companions of his own so that could end
up being a big clue as to something
about the future but I'm going to save
that for another video also please let
me know if you think John's going to be
successful in this mission do you
actually think he's going to be able to
capture a white and get it back down
south
do you think Daenerys is actually going
to show up just in time to save the day
but the big question is do you think the
night king is going to be able to kill
one of her dragons and raise it from the
dead for himself to ride let me know
your thoughts about this I'm very
curious to see if this actually happens
I really want to know how Daenerys would
react if one of her dragons would die
and then she would eventually have to
fight one of her own dragons we know she
looks at those dragons like they're her
kids so what is that going to do to her
psychologically if she loses one to the
night king could she potentially go down
a darker path like Cersei when she
started to lose her kids I'm really
looking forward to seeing how that's
going to play out if this is true but
before I go I have to give a big
shout-out to my friend White's King over
on Twitter if you do not follow him on
Twitter yet he definitely should he is
an amazing artist and he makes all these
great digital images that I'm sure most
of you have seen circulating online he
has created many Game of Thrones related
digital photos and he was nice enough to
let me use this
sheriff Johnson Oh for my thumbnail I
really appreciate that and I'm going to
put his link to Twitter down in my
description that way you can go follow
him and check out all of his other
artwork but I want to thank all of you
for stopping by and I want to give a big
shout out to Dennis Chadwick he donated
$20.00 to my patreon last night I was
pretty shocked when I got the email no
one has ever donated $20.00 before I
cannot thank you enough Dennis that was
very kind of you but I also must thank
all the patreon supporters because no
matter what amount you use to support
the channel with I appreciate it
tremendously thanks again and I'll see
you all down in the comments bye